[Applaudissements]
bonjour vous avez
de l'eau aujourd'hui je veux dire vous
avez bu de l'eau propre
certainement cela vous paraît normal
banal
pourtant pour de nombreuses personnes
c'est un véritable exploit
il faut marcher plusieurs heures pour
aller jusqu'à la rivière avec un fort
dénivelé
ensuite il faut remonter avec des bidons
des sceaux de 5 à 25 litres
ce sont généralement les enfants et les
femmes qui sont chargés de cette corvée
journalières mais cette eau est souvent
contaminés par des matières fécales des
bactéries des virus des parasites
l'onu estime que 30% de la population
mondiale voit une eau sale avec des
conséquences des conséquences terribles
c'est que deux millions de personnes
vont mourir chaque année à cause des
maladies hydriques
vous l'avez compris je vais vous parler
de l'accès à l'eau potable dans les pays
du sud
comment cela se passe là bas et ce à
travers mon expérience de ces 25
dernières années ou avec mes équipes
nous avons installé plus de 350 projets
pour permettre à quatre millions de
personnes d'avoir de l'eau prenons une
ville comme kikwit l'équivalent de lyon
en république démocratique du congo un
million d'habitants à part dont les
installations sont obsolètes
le réservoir d'eau fui les pompes ne
marche pas
la population a doublé en très peu de
temps les autorités ont besoin
d'investir rapidement les besoins sont
immenses mais les caisses de l'état sont
vides
on va donc les autorités vont faire
appel aux bailleurs de fonds les banques
de développement
il en existe plus d'une centaine la
banque mondiale la banque africaine de
développement l'agencé française de
développement
elles ont pour mission d'accorder des
crédits à des taux d'intérêt très
faibles sur une période très
hong si le dossier retenu à un bureau
d'études va être sélectionné il va faire
l'inventaire de l'existant
combien de kilomètres de conduite il
faut changer est ce qu'on fait un
nouveau réservoir ou est-ce qu'on
réhabilite l'existant et il va définir
un budget deuxième étape on va faire un
avant projet détaillé
cette fois ci avec la liste des
équipements et des ouvrages à réaliser à
partir de là on va sélectionner une
entreprise de travaux qui va livrer et
installer et mettre en route les
équipements tout cela apparaît assez
fluide mais sur le terrain très vite on
va s'apercevoir qu'entre la vision de
l'ingénieur qui rêve de smart cities et
les attentes de appelons la madame
diallo
il y a tout un monde elle veut que l'eau
en bas de la rivière soit pompée filtre
et désinfecter stocker et distribuer
rapidement là cette année le plus
rapidement possible pour tous les
acteurs qui réalise le projet c'est une
crise de nerfs permanente
le projet est surdimensionné il ya eu
plusieurs intervenants rien ne marche
comme prévu et les conséquences pour le
maire de kikwit
c'est qu'entre le moment où il a exprimé
ses besoins et le moment où il va y
enfin avoir l'eau au robinet il y a huit
à quinze ans une éternité
le prix de revient du mètre cube d'eau
est de 8 $
ici à lyon vous payez trois de leurs
cinq ans tessa a comprend la taxe
d'assainissement
on sait qu'en afrique la plupart des
gens la grande majorité peuvent payer
maximum 1 $ du mètre cube
alors est ce une fatalité
non bien sûr est ce qu'il y a des
solutions
oui
la première c'est que les budgets pour
l'eau potable dans le monde augmente en
1848 il y avait une très belle phrase
sur les affiches de la révolution nul
n'a droit au superflu tant que chacun
n'a pas le nécessaire
il va falloir donc mettre en place des
taxes des impôts sur le superflu mais un
autre niveau que pouvons nous faire
nous sommes un groupe d'hommes et de
femmes de terrain et depuis cinq ans
nous réfléchissons sur comment changer
de logiciel trouver de nouveaux modèles
pour aller plus vite que ça fonctionne
que ça dure dans le temps et que ce soit
duplicable l'une des idées que je vais
vous soumettre consiste à mettre
ensemble un bureau d'études
une société de travaux une société
d'exploitation ou des dalles
exploitation pour ensemble répondre à
des appels d'offres de conception et
réalisation intégré dès le début
l'ingénierie sociale être à l'écouté des
usagers
le client lui va avoir trois exigences
très simples un que les offres chiffrées
qui vont lui être remises ne dépasse pas
le prix plancher d'un dollar
deuxièmement que tout soit fait
rapidement en un an un an et demi
maximum
troisièmement que les entreprises
s'engagent à garantir la maintenance
pendant 5 10 et 15 ans cela va avoir des
conséquences bénéfiques
les entreprises vont s'adapter à ce prix
plancher il y à des solutions techniques
la plus simple c'est déjà de réduire le
débit par habitant on apprend dans les
écoles d'ingénieurs à strasbourg en
allemagne en espagne qu'il faut 150
litres d'eau par habitant
on s'est très bien pertinemment que
personne ne peut payer 150 litres d'eau
en afrique on est entre 20 et 50 litres
sera permet de réduire les installations
réduire les investissements
le délai très court va obliger les
entreprises à acheter local
inutile de faire venir des contenaires
de chine d'allemagne de turquie
s'il y a des usines au congo il y en a
ou dans la sous-région à abidjan au
ghana au kenya
parce que dans trois ans quand vous
allez casser un tuyau et ça arrive
si vous n'avez pas la même marque le
même diamètre tout s'arrête j'ai vu des
installations pour centaines d'euros un
contacteur tombé en panne
on peut aussi imaginer de pomper une eau
brute dans la rivière faire une
filtration grossière et qu'ensuite elles
soient traitées chez l'habitant avec des
petits filtre à sable fabriqué
localement des réservoirs on en trouve
partout et on intègre une membranes
d'ultrafiltration qui va arrêter toutes
les bactéries tous les virus tous les
parasites pour les bidonvilles des
boutiques à eau sont installés alimenté
soit par le réseau soit par camion l'eau
va être traitée filtré sur place vendue
au bidon comme ça se fait souvent mais
aussi on peut alimenter dans un rayon de
1500 m les 500 familles et elles ont la
possibilité de payer avec leur téléphone
mobile
ça se fait énormément elles peuvent
payer un demi dollar un dollar par jour
parce qu'on est face à un public qui ne
peut pas payer 30 ou 40 dollars à la fin
du mois ensuite vu l'enjeu on parle de 2
milliards de personnes qui boivent une
eau sale dans les cas où le prix de
revient on n'arriverait pas à ce prix
est ce qu'on peut pas imaginer qu'un
gouvernement une institution une banque
de développement université compense ce
prix vous allez me dire non ce matin
j'ai pris le tramway
j'ai payé un euro 80 le prix du ticket
ne couvre qu'un quart de
l'investissement et des frais de
fonctionnement
le reste c'est la ville de lyon la
région l'agglo l'état qui subventionne
parce que lyon sans moyen de transport
en commun
ce serait des heures d'embouteillages du
temps perdu de la pollution des crises
d'asthme des morts pour l'eau potable
c'est pareil c'est à dire que les
enfants vous avez vu tout à l'heure au
lieu de
passé quatre heures par jour tous les
jours à transporter des sauces ils
pouvaient aller à l'école
s'il pouvait si les parents au lieu de
courir au dispensaire tous les trois
quatre mois pour acheter des
antibiotiques
tout le monde serait gagnant mesdames
messieurs vous le voyez les solutions
existent il faut les mettre en place
rapidement
il y a urgence merci
[Applaudissements]